[Music]
welcome to the first invited talk of the
third day of the consumer science summit
2020
my name is salal hummer i am a senior
principal scientist at ipc
and i will be your host for this talk
it's my distinct pleasure to invite our
speaker gerard geshon gerard is a
professor at the wharton school
university of pennsylvania
he studies supply chain management
operations strategy and pricing
with a focus on how technology
transforms and enables
novel business strategies he's an
informs fellow a fellow and a former
president of msom the manufacturing and
service operations management society
he's the former editor-in-chief of
management science as well as
manufacturing and service
operations management msom he has
authored
two textbooks operations management and
matching supply with demand and
introduction to operations management
these books have been used in
undergraduate mba and executive mba
courses at horton
as well as at numerous other business
schools throughout the world
he has published in management science
manufacturing and service operations
management
marketing science operations research
quarter leader nano economics
harvard business review among many
others jarrod will talk to us today
uh on human versus robot workers in our
fulfillment center in fulfillment center
pick processes so before i hand over to
gerard there are a couple of
housekeeping items
uh many of you probably know it by now
the the talk will be approximately 30
minutes
uh during the talk uh please type any
questions you might have into the
broadcast
chat bar if you are unable to
see the comments being loaded there is a
little button on top of the chat bar
called login to crier you may need to
sign in with your midway authentication
token
at the end of the talk i'll select a few
questions that i'll read out to gerard
and uh to his co-author omar
and um they can answer them and after
the session
after the q a which is about 20 minutes
we will have a virtual coffee break of
about 10 minutes
or more informal exchanges we'll type
the chinese session id
into the chat bar for those who want to
attend the coffee session
uh thank you for joining us today and
enjoy the talk
over to you gerard thank you very much
salah and uh
thank you to uh everyone at amazon uh
for attending and uh inviting me to the
this
session to present this research i'm
quite excited to do this
uh when i was given the invitation they
asked me what would you like to talk
about it turns out i was
working on a a topic that
is quite close to amazon it's basis on
visits we've made to the amazon
fulfillment centers
um and so it's uh quite
quite special for me to be able to
present research on about a comp
inspired by a company to
uh the company and uh i'd like to
mention right off the bat that this is
joint work with omar vespas
omar was a colleague of mine at penn for
a little while and now
is a professor at the columbia
business school so as you can see from
the title here
human versus robot workers and
fulfillment center pick processes
i'm going to use throughout this uh talk
the notion of human workers and robot
workers
you can think of robot workers as being
like those you know
old the kiva ones that now are called
drives
uh amazon robotics ar uh
human you might think of it as sort of
the classic uh
way in which warehouses would work in
which humans would go around a warehouse
with a grocery cart almost picking items
from the warehouse
okay so here's
as you know warehouse operations are
incredibly complicated
and so we want to simplify this down
into order
so we can understand the trade-offs that
are going on between
the two different ways in which you can
uh
uh these two different ways of which you
can operate uh your
your warehouse so here's what i want you
to have in mind
visually is that instead of a huge
warehouse huge big rectangle
uh take a strip of that warehouse a long
strip of it
and there's inventory stored along that
strip
i'm going to call that the inventory
storage area so that's where all the
stuff is that needs that gets demanded
by customers
that needs to get picked uh workers are
going to go into that
storage area pick the stuff or well
there's different ways
well i'll explain the different ways
they run it but the stuff is picked in
that storage area and it's brought to a
drop-off station that's sort of on the
side
uh from the drop-off station it goes
into sorting machines eventually goes
into packaging i'm not looking we're not
looking
at anything about the subsequent
processes
after the drop-off station we're also
not going to be looking at
the inbound you know we're stowing of
the inventory into the storage area
we're really focused in on just the pick
process which by many accounts is one of
the more labor intensive
processes in in fulfillment centers
so the objective that we have in mind
here is
trying to understand different ways of
operating
uh this fulfillment center will
influence
the number of workers you have in the
fulfillment center a
worker in quotes means that could either
be a drive or can be a human
and we're going to minimize that amount
of work that's in the system subject to
a response time constraint so i want you
to have in mind
that there is some constraint that
you've imposed on your
on a warehouse say i i want to be able
to complete the pick process on
average within 10 hours within six hours
within one hour you know there's
different
uh those that's sort of the time scale
that we're going to be thinking about
here
so if you're doing let's say a one or
two day delivery a
average pick time of 10 hours is
potentially quite
uh reasonable if you're doing two hour
delivery though
uh your average response time is going
to have to be you know
less than two hours for sure so we're
gonna be interested in stress testing
these systems to understand
how do they work under relatively long
average response times let's say
10 hours uh and also how they work on
relatively short
response times something like uh one
hour
all right so let me describe the two
different uh
versions of this system specifically the
first one is the human
the manual the traditional pick process
this is where
human beings kind of walk into the
inventory storage area
they're given a route they're given a
pick order they go and they pick items
and then they bring them back to the
drop-off station so sometimes this is
called a
picker to parts system because the
well the workers go in first and
selection of
items occurs before the movement to the
drop-off station
in contrast as you guys know uh you
could operate these with
robots slash pods uh the way
these robots work is that the inventory
is stored in
pods the robot goes underneath the pod
lifts it up
and moves it around the robot it only
moves the pods it's unable to select
inventory so what happens is the
pod is moved to a the drop-off station
where now a
set of humans does the selecting of the
inventory from the pod
then the robot brings the pod back into
the inventory storage area
here this is called a parts to picker
system
where movement occurs before selection
so this is the key distinction between
these
what's the sequence do you select before
you move or do you move
before you select and then of course
what's the significance
of these two uh okay
so those are the two different systems
that we have and we're going to be
considering how they again
the objective is minimize the number of
workers a worker being either a robot or
a pod
subject to an average response time
constraint
now i'm going to start you off with our
main
finding result and hopefully that'll get
you a little bit intrigued about what
we're finding
and then i'm going to go ahead and
explain
give you the details behind it so if you
have to leave after you know
two more minutes then at least you'll
get the the punchline of the talk here
so what i've shown in this graph is on
the x-axis the response time and i
mentioned before like a tight
response time might be one hour all the
way to
a loose response time of 10 hours and
on the y-axis here i've got roughly the
number of workers
so i've also normalized it
to something that i'll mention later on
but let's let's sort of think of this
this point right here is where i'm
normalizing the number of workers
and then i am plotting out the number of
workers you need in the two systems and
what you visually see
is that relatively speaking the human
system
is robust to response time yes
when the response time gets quite short
the human system requires a few more
workers but not much the effect is
pretty minimal
however with the robot system uh the
effect is actually pretty
uh pretty significant so you might be
for example
at a one hour response time something
like a factor of four
times more robots needed uh relative to
the number of robots you would have in a
human system
at 10 hours and so the rest of the talk
is i'm roughly going to be trying to
explain
the difference here and kind of why
we're having this different behavior
with respect to response time
or at least that's what we're seeing all
right so that's the main result now
let's get into
uh background and then uh the details so
uh really briefly on the literature uh
there is a huge literature on warehouse
operations
um i've listed here one particular
review paper
on all different kinds of aspects of
warehouse operations
most of those things are very tactical
uh let me kind of divide it into
two other relevant uh subsets is one is
a
set of papers on how to operate a picker
to parts
uh system and so these will focus things
on
uh how do you construct routes for the
workers how many items should they pick
where should they be picking them in the
warehouse i
they go into many more complexities than
we will do for example because
because we're looking at a a single line
a long line of a warehouse routing is
far
less of a complication we're doing it
mostly just in two-dimensional space not
three-dimensional space
uh and then of course recently there's a
bunch of papers that are really focused
in on the
the robot system the parts to picker
system and again looking at how should
you organize
your warehouse how should you organize
your robots etc
some of the things that they will
consider that we're not really
focused in so much in is recognizing
that
items will have different demand rates
and so
should you put your fast items closer
farther away
should you put fast items on the same
pod or not
we're going to simplify away from that
and just assume that
uh all items across the the span of
inventory are selling at the same
same rate it's easy to extend it but
again we're that's not the main focus of
what we're looking at here
so in contrast to diving into sort of
the technical details of how do you
actually
optimize these systems we're much more
interested in comparing the systems and
hence we're going to be
looking at it sort of a higher higher
level
okay so i want to start you off with
thinking first and foremost about what's
the minimum capacity that you need in
this system
you can think of these systems as sort
of involving two things one is you need
a certain amount of work to just get
done so that you can do this task and
then there's going to be issues about
congestion
robots that are idle pods that are idle
human workers that are idle
in this part of the talk i'm just
focusing on a minimum amount of work
needed to get the job done
and so we can abstract away from a lot
of complexities by just saying
the average amount of work that's being
put onto the system
has to equal the amount of work that's
supplied by the system
and you end up with an equation that
looks something like what i have here
which is
uh the arrival rate of work which is the
lambda
and i want you to think in terms of
something like two items every minute
just give you a sense of scale um
and then there's going to be what what's
the work done well you have to you have
to do the
the actual picking so that's going to be
the pick time
or selection time think something like
10 seconds to pick an item from a bin
you have to do some walking
so if you walk halfway up and halfway
back that's a total of
total w amount of walk that you're doing
in the system and let's normalize
distance as in you move one unit of
distance per
unit per second so that uh it's we have
units compatibility easily
and then q is the number of units that
you're picking
on each route okay so you can think of
dividing the work of w
over q units uh and then multiplying it
by the rate at work
that has to your number of workers you
have has to be at least
greater than that and that's if
everybody was 100
utilized now what we can gain from this
equation
is to no you're not really going to want
to play around with your lambda you're
not going to mess around with demand you
really have only then three
three levers here uh you have the
selection time
the the what the size of the warehouse
and then the queue
for the sake of comparison we could we
could say that t would be different
between the two systems or we're going
to assume it's the same for now
we could assume that the warehouses were
different sizes but we're going to
assume it's the same for now so really
the control variable you got
is is the queue it's this how many items
get picked per route
and that's going to be the critical
factor that's going to influence the
capacity
in the system so we need a policy for
the humans and we need some results for
the
the robot system neither of them are
tractable there's no hope you're going
to find an optimal policy for either of
them so what we're what we've done is
we've come up with a strategy of
thinking let's find out a
feasible policy for the human system a
reasonable policy
see how it performs and then we're going
to compare it to
a policy that we know or a lower bound
for the robot system
and that gap will be a conservative
estimate of the difference
so our policy for the human system is
going to divide
the warehouse into m zones
and then within each zone we're just
going to count up demands as they occur
once you get to q demands which is the
number of items a human can pick
you generate a route you end up with a
queue of routes
humans get assigned these routes on a
first come first serve basis
notice there's nothing dynamic really
about this it's not like if a human is
walking by and you want to change the
routes
none of that complexity really simple
policy of just divided into m zones
equal zone equal size zones every q
units within a zone generates a route
that goes into a queue
first come first serve picking and so
this ends up being a ggnq
which if you you know that is there's
good approximations for it but
there's nothing that's really exact on
this
in this space because it's just too
complex
okay so how are we going to analyze this
a little bit
i want you to think in terms of there's
essentially
three components that are are
contributing to the response time
in an m zone policy uh the first one
is you have to accumulate uh some
it takes time for q units to accumulate
to form the route within the zone
then there's going to be some congestion
in in terms of the the routes have to
wait in a queue
this formula here is known to be a good
approximation for ggnq
uh and so we're going to be using it in
our in our analysis here
uh it's based essentially on uh u which
is the utilization of the system
coefficients of variation of arrival and
service processes
um and then i'll show you the equation
for the u right there
and then finally once you once the human
uh once the route gets picked up by the
human the human actually has to do the
route which is you have to select
plus you have to move and that's
influenced by m so what we
what we see is that the totality of
these three components has to be less
than our response time
okay so note for example that as m gets
bigger
uh the accumulation the time to
accumulate the route
gets bigger which is bad however your
processing times go down
you become more efficient with respect
to routing and both and then of course m
also will have an impact on the u
which will in fact wait all right so
taking this and doing a couple of uh
simplifications in terms of making it an
upper bound we're going to
ditch this exponent we're going to
evaluate this as an upper bound we're
going to assume it's a
it's a renewal process with cva of one
that allows us to get to this equation
which essentially says
okay to minimize n we have to do uh
we have to pick m's and u's in this
left-hand side
subject to some adjusted response time
constraint think of it as the response
time
minus some selection minus the worst
case scenario walking up and down the
whole warehouse
this can be solved analytically
but it turns out you can do a little
trick which is
simply budget your your time into two
buckets
and so i've just relaxed this
optimization problem and i've made it a
lot easier
that comes to this like we can come to
now a nice clean
closed form solution uh
for an m zone policy now what i want you
to do is uh look at a couple of things
first of all this is the lower bound
that we had before
and this is the answer that we're
getting with the feasible policy and as
you can see there's a
it looks there's a lot of that lower
bound in there
where does it differ well it differs by
a an adjustment due to utilization
so that you want to you want these
humans to be busy
high heel is not utilized and you want
this term to be relatively small
and it turns out both both those cases
are going to be true because
let's just look at the utilization
utilization is going to be some ratio
and the response time you know
at about seven or eight hours is like 20
000 seconds
and then this thing is measured in
hundreds so you got 20
000 divided by 20 000 plus something of
hundreds your u is going to be
you're gonna be running this thing in
heavy traffic you're nearly in heavy
traffic
and then your m has a probability of
order of magnitude of like 20 to
50. so that when you go here you know
you're dividing by
something at 20 or 50 that's getting
that terms pretty small this u is almost
one you're pretty much going to be close
to this lower bound even though this
feasible policy made a lot of
approximations and assumptions okay
so now let's go to the the robots the
key difference between the human and the
robot system is that
in the human system we assume that the
queue is fixed like every human always
picks
10 items in the robot system though it's
going to be
a function of how you operate because
you don't get you know the
how many demands are occurring on the
pod will vary
based on how long these pods have been
cycling around in the system
so we're going to assume that demand can
occur on a pot at any time
we're going to form a queue of these
posit once a demand occurs it becomes
available for pickup
then it waits eventually a robot picks
it up brings it to the drop-off station
and drops it off so again we can sort of
decouple time like we did before
uh and what we end up with is this is
the equation that it kind of expresses
the relationship between the number of
items on the
on the pod that is picked the q
which is now endogenous and the
constraint of the response time
tau right and so what we can see is that
um if if we want a larger queue if we
want to be able to pick more items on
each pod we have to relax
that response time constraint has to go
it has to go up a little bit
okay and then in terms of notation we've
also picked
m here and so what m is a little bit
different before it was the number of
zones but in some sense you can think of
a robot policy as
operating one zone for every pod
and hence now with the robots unlike
before
m is now fixed and q becomes endogenous
whereas with the human system
q was fixed and and m was the choice
variable
so it's the key it's the difference
those are the two variables that get
swapped between the two different
systems
okay so then we can take this equation
solve for q
this gives us what our how many units
we'll be able to pick on the system
subject to a response time constraint
and then we can just throw this into the
lower bound and see how well it performs
now no
this lower bound is not considering any
forms of congestion
however based on our preliminary
simulation results a we are
this bound is pretty darn accurate and
the get it's a
pretty good estimate for what we think
might be a feasible policy
that being said uh the feasible policy
is going to be much more complicated
in this robot system uh and therefore
the
analysis of it will be more complex but
we are optimistic that this is probably
a reasonably tight bound
okay so now let me give you sort of
some scale parameters for what we're
thinking about in terms of what we think
are reasonable numbers here so
uh we're thinking our the length of the
warehouse
is some like something like a hundred
remember these are measured in
in distance uh that you can travel
per second so think of it as it it takes
you 100 seconds
a little 100 seconds to walk from one
end of the warehouse to the other
days of supply we picked 40
so we're going to assume the fc operates
20 hours a day that translates into that
lambda
we can see here roughly that's about one
unit every 30 seconds or two units every
every minute pick time of about 10
seconds we're going to assume
humans can pick about 10 items
this translates into about 500 pods in
the system
and we're going to estimate roughly
about 200 items on each pod
okay none of these are you know none of
these are particularly important
for our qualitative results but just
give you a sense of where we are with
our
what we think are sort of within the
parameters of reasonable scope for
an actual operation so that brings us
back to the
the graph that i said was the aha or the
main punch line which is
essentially that the human system uh is
far less sensitive
than the the robot system to response
time constraints
and remember again this robot this curve
right here is is the lower bound so the
real policy is actually going to be
something bigger than that we're not
exactly sure how much bigger we think
it's reasonably close but it is bigger
whereas the the human system that is a
feasible policy
so that there might be something better
however
this is the lower bound and so what you
can see is this thing converges to its
lower bound
really quickly um and this pretty much
applies in many different kinds of uh
scenarios that we've been
that we've been looking at right so
what is this what is it you know judging
this you say well first of all
humans don't cost the same as robots
understood uh so
you would have a depending on the
context a robot might be
much cheaper than a human at which point
if you're operating here you say okay
i'm using a few more
robots than i would that would with
humans but big deal they're so much
cheaper
uh okay fine that might be true however
if you're
if you're committed to a robot system
and you want to know how many robots you
need to go from here
to here you're looking at a three to
four factor fold increase
in the number of robots you would need
if you wanted to really push your system
to
a very fast response time so i guess the
warning here would be
if you are if you feel like you're
running with a lean number of robots
with a large response time don't assume
that the
number of robots you'll be able to
operate with with a faster response time
shorter response time would be
anywhere near the same number now what's
going on here well i i'm plotting in
this one
the number of average picks per
pod and as i mentioned before the human
system it's always a constant
10 um in the it's endogenous in the
robot system so as you
as you have more time to wait your q
goes up but the problem is that your q
is going up relatively slowly and so
throughout this whole range
the robot system uh is not picking as
much
as uh the human and as a result
uh especially when you're down here you
know you only wonder
one one and a half picks per pod you're
gonna need a lot of robots to run that
system then because they're just
traveling around
uh moving a lot of inventory without
much
work getting done now how would this
how would the story change under uh
different kind of put you know
parameters and pushing it well the
one obvious one to do is well what
happens if your inventory is actually
moving a lot faster so instead of a days
of supply of 40
the average inventory spends only 10
days
uh in the warehouse so it's moving mark
it's moving more quickly
well because it's moving more quickly
that's going to actually give the
advantage to the robot system
because it'll be able to accumulate
uh demands on the pods a lot faster for
any given response time
so if you have a six hour response time
instead of having four picks
uh on average uh with 40 days of supply
you know it might it might jump up much
higher
that being said though the basic result
that a robot system experiences
uh far more robots needed
once you start pushing the uh response
time closer to this like one hour
that continues to hold it's just that
the crossing over point
uh varies now another thing you might
say is well
uh robot one advantage of a robot system
which is true
is that robots uh allow you to pack your
inventory a little bit
tighter so the w really shouldn't be the
same
across uh the two systems
fair enough so what you could do is then
you know analyze both systems with
uh different w's this is an example of
what you would see in the robot system
if it required 20 less space
than the human system whether you can
get that amount of compression or not is
something that would be an empirical
observation i'm just giving you a sense
of it
still you're seeing the same effect
which is that
at really low response times the robot
system is going to require a lot more
robots than humans
fewer because now you they're moving
fewer distance because they're taking
advantage of that compression but
even if that w were to go you know you
would have to really compress it a lot
in order for that green line to move
towards that
all the way down to that orange line and
you could do the same thing now with the
t parameters so remember the t
what we said is like 10 seconds to pick
if it's the case that
humans are able to pick items
uh at a drop-off station when a robot
brings it to them
faster than they could while they're
walking the stacks
you could uh you could um
include that in the analysis for sure
right
okay so what do i want you to take away
from from this talk
and the first thing is that these
systems
uh take away all that complexity the key
thing is that
batching is absolutely essential for
understanding the efficiency of the
number of workers you're going to have
in the system uh
batching meaning how many items are
picked per
route um if you're moving robots and
they're only picking one item per route
that's going to require a lot of robots
uh if humans can walk around and pick 30
or 40 items per hour they're going to do
a lot less
walking and
the two different systems have different
abilities to
create that batching so
when you you operate the human system
you're essentially
batching over space uh roughly you're
going to talk about you're talking about
20 to 50 zones would be an optimal
number
uh relative to 500 zones with the
number of pods in the pod system so
instead of having to batch over just the
inventory in one pod the human can walk
around a little bit
and grab a whole much more inventory so
it's far easier
for the human to batch because it's
doing it over
space the only way the robot can batch
is doing it over time
because a robot can't move multiple pots
hence it's stuck to the amount of
inventory in a single pod and it's got
to wait for the demand in that single
pod to accumulate and the only way to do
that
is is over time consequently the human
system has a lot less of an impact with
respect to response time
than the the robot system the robot
system is very sensitive to time because
at the short response times
it doesn't have enough time to
accumulate the demands on the pods which
is going to make the
the batching efficiency kick in